Speaker 1: All right. What? Just one more.
One more Herschel Walker clip for today.
It's totally unrelated to the abortion scandal.
I just want to let you all know that Herschel
Walker has now jumped on the electric vehicle
tirades, I think is what we're calling them.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE has been blasting electric
vehicles while understanding very little about
it. Trump has been attacking electric vehicles
to some degree. Here is Herschel Walker visibly
confused about electric vehicles, what they
are, how they work. And this is now a theme
among Republicans. They're very, very angry
about something they don't really understand.
Speaker 3: You know, you're talking about an
electric car, right? Solar panels right now. Solar
panels. I want to. For groceries and for eggs
and milk. You talk about me getting solar panels,
giving me a tax credit to buy an electric car.
This car is more than my house, so I'll put a
solar panel on my roof, on my house, on the roof
of my car. Oh, and that's what I'm living in,
as in let's get down to the true facts. The true
facts are. This is not a new normal for right?
Speaker 1: This is definitely not. I hope that
candidates like Herschel Walker are not the new
normal now. Oftentimes, I'll look online
at different, you know, discussions about
electric vehicles and the exact same stuff that
Herschel Walker is saying here. It's all confused.
It's gobbledygook. It doesn't make any sense.
It's the same stuff that many of the anti electric
vehicle people say in their online forums. They're
tapping out these angry messages furiously.
It's the exact same stuff that many of the anti
electric vehicle people email me about. Okay. It
might not hurt him at all in the polls because a
lot of the people already supporting him believe
all the same stuff that he's saying, oh, they
want to force these expensive vehicles on us.
You've got to take it point by point on price.
The mini S.C. Electric and the Nissan Leaf are
under $30,000. The Chevy Bolt and the Mazda MX
30 are just over $30,000. As new vehicles use,
they are even less. You will save on gas,
so some of the cost now is made up for later
as you don't have to pay for the gas that
they say is so overpriced and expensive in
terms of the cars costs more than houses. I'm
aware of houses in some parts of the country
that are like 30 grand. I am. I recently became
aware that there are $30,000 houses. But Herschel
Walker has a multimillion dollar mansion. And so
the electric vehicles are definitely not more than
his house, that's for sure. Now, there are real
problems with electric vehicles to be solved.
There's real problems with internal combustion
engine vehicles as well. We could be working on
solving the problems with electric vehicles rather
than dealing with these very silly and uninformed
attacks. Well, there's not enough charging
stations. All right. Well, Joe Biden's trying to
work on that and just put forward a bunch of money
in the infrastructure bill to build more charging
stations of electric vehicles. Don't fix the issue
of just too many individual people driving around
in cars. We would be much better off with maybe
more work from home, combined with better funding,
public transit and just get cars off the road.
Great and electric vehicles better than an
internal combustion engine. But it would be better
for that person not to be driving around in an
individual vehicle anyway. Well, but Republicans
are against funding public transit, the material
intensity and the waste and the need for so-called
conflict minerals for electric vehicles and
batteries. What do we do with the batteries after
their useful life is over? There are real issues
here, like with just about anything that exists
on our planet. They will improve with time, but
they will improve much more quickly. If, instead
of fighting idiotic statements about electric
vehicles like the ones we've heard from Herschel
Walker and Marjorie Taylor GREENE and others,
if we would actually spend time dealing with the
problems better than internal combustion engine,
of course. Can it improve even further? Yes. But
these Republicans are actively trying to sabotage
it. They really are horrible. All of the clips
I've played for you in these first three segments,
you can watch them on our Instagram at David
Pakman show and you can react. Let me know
what you think about that and TV nonsense
by finding me on Twitter at David Pakman.